but to get access to women who are
respectful who are appreciative who are
not talking to you out of the side of
their neck that's worth it to a man what
you got what role do you think that uh
like uh socioeconomic status has on
keeping women feminine do you think the
poor women are the more feminine they
are or if you for example if you bring
or take her from a lifestyle where she's
like in a Countryside port or whatever
her country and then you even moved to
her country but yet you bring your money
with you all of a sudden she's more does
that bring more entitlement as well no
no it doesn't because the culture around
her does not promote that entitlement if
you were in I would not ever recommend
that a man moved to Russia if you like
Russian girls [ __ ] can't even really
move to Ukraine
just wait until yeah wait until wait
until that that's all situated with
Putin and and the boys I have a lot of
different nannies from other countries
yeah
kids yeah they're kind of feminists I
low-key I Loki would recommend Germany
but Germany is Germany is in a lot of
trouble uh yeah economically it's uh
there's a guy in my in my uh I meant the
women oh the women yeah okay well go get
a German woman and then maybe move to
Croatia yeah I don't know if they I just
I was just thinking like which ones made
the best nannies growing up I'm like the
Germans they just it they are a little
bit feministy though sure but like they
do submit to their Med they're like
they'll talk this game they'll be
they'll be like I don't submit and then
they'll be cooking in breakfast right
and wear nothing but apron and heels
yeah listen listen tell your girlfriends
whatever you got to tell them you got to
be you gotta be strong for your
girlfriends uh it is what it is
um oh Asia they have the best outcomes I
recommend Asia yeah listen you know
fever and all that good stuff but you
but you gotta live out there dude MLD
Jonathan he and and really depends on
what your family situation is John
Jonathan MLD came from [ __ ] nothing
like this dude this dude grew up dirt
poor this dude clawed his way out of
poverty and now he's worth seven figures
but his family situation was very
chaotic he was raised by a single mom
his dad his dad is an alpha Chad his dad
had a one night stand I think with his
mom MLD if I'm if I'm messing that up I
apologize but uh uh MLD grew up in chaos
he doesn't really have the same kind of
family structure that you do your family
structure is very rare but he said you
know what I mean listen my family ain't
[ __ ] American women ain't [ __ ] he moved
to Japan he's not coming back and that's
and that's that's the thing like a lot
of modern women don't realize your kids
will grow up and see what you did yes
yes like a lot of them like they think
that the kids are stupid I'm like
they're young there might be naive but
one day they're gonna wake up and
realize their mom's a hoe who put
herself first my whole life oh my God
and they're gonna and you're and people
are gonna find out yeah we just saw
proof of that with uh Kim Kardashian
getting uh not only booed at the Rams
game but yeah but people shouting out
her calling her a hoe in front of her
kids and all and telling her she why
isn't she sucking a you know what and
like like in front of her family yeah
actions have consequences man and Kim
Kardashian has done such she's done such
a good job promoting this this this
whole lifestyle
I I really wonder I'd really I'd really
be interested to find out what she
thinks of that like what like Kim like
in an honest moment what are Kim and
Courtney and Chloe our kids are they
gonna find out what the hell is going on
and what do we do yeah and
and that's the thing like I'm I'm really
big into like women you can do what you
want to do yeah of course can you can't
do what you want to do but like don't
complain later yes yes life is about
choices and like Kevin always say life
is about choices and trade-offs and
everything you do has risks that's right
there is no guaranteed good outcome like
you could you could do everything right
and still have a bad outcome this is and
a lot this is what a lot of guys a lot
of men will complain
um oh women aren't this and women aren't
that but what men don't understand is
that there are no guarantees none
sometimes sometimes you're just not
compatible if that's just how it is I
tell guys all the time you can do
everything right and the [ __ ] can still
be [ __ ] up now doing everything right
and still having things blow up in your
face that's that's it's more likely to
happen here in the states than anywhere
else but nothing comes without risk and
there are so many guys in this community
who want a completely risk-free girl
she's got to be a virgin I'm not
committed anyone who's not a virgin
who's not hot who doesn't know how to
cook who doesn't daddy she was like
guess what now now we gotta break out
the Meyer and uh now we got to break out
the fresh and fit delusion calculator
because those girls just don't exist fam
yeah
yeah and get a virgin but the virgins I
just said this earlier The Virgins of
today aren't the virgins of yes no
they're not they are curious they're
yeah they're curious and I I've heard
story after story after Story of like oh
I I had a virgin girl and then like she
started to get curious and she left here
we go and I know like the stat is like
that virgins have an 80 chance of a
happy marriage but I'm like that's if
you get them down the aisle
and I'm Pro like waiting like I think
that's great yeah and I would say if
that's like that that's probably your
best bet if you can get one but like
good luck it's it's it really it really
is it's a sad State of Affairs
um between men and women but this is why
this is why I do what I do because I
want people to be happy I want people I
want men and women to have I want men
and women to have good relationships I
really really do because I've lived that
player of life and as much fun as it was
and I say this all the time as much fun
as it was my life is 10 times better
than it I mean don't get me wrong I will
dude the Las Vegas was a Magic Carpet
Ride but it really really was dude oh
dude I don't think I've ever been more
excited dude 95 of the girls I have ever
banged right there in Las Vegas that's
really where I became who I was but but
what it comes down to is that there are
costs of that lifestyle a half a million
dollar legal bill that I had to pay for
all of the trouble that I got into I
snorted my weight in I snorted my weight
in Coca-Cola while I was there I don't
can't tell you how many thousands of
dollars I blew on that chasing girls to
do this and and it was really just kind
of a waste of time but there's something
to be said about being in a good
relationship with a woman that you
really do love and not not necessarily
trust but trust that she will follow
your leadership because the player life
is listen Myron and fresh are exactly
who I was 10 years ago it was girls and
car I mean dude I've had all that you
know and it's a great time but
relationships meant Uh Kevin says this
alt as he used to say this all the time
men and women we're better together man
we are so much better together
unfortunately we've never been worse and
it's like this is why I exist I want to
show guys hey you know what it's a lot
harder than it used to be and it's it's
next to impossible to have the kind of
relationship that satisfies both the man
and the woman but
uh I mean I gotta keep I gotta keep
fighting the good fight yeah and all you
can do is like work with what you got
and move forward yeah that's that's why
I'm doing 304 to Life School for the for
the hoes that want to be better
some of y'all are stuck in the streets
forever if you want to be oh let's the
streets is cold and I will I will ask
you to do anything that I have not done
I'm trying to learn
I will not I will not ask you to do
anything I have not done so this Hoda
housewife school is this going to be a
spoof or is this going to be for real
um well kind of both yeah I have to make
it entertaining of course no like I
can't of course I I can't spend money on
something and not record no of course
not of course but as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible